we're here with ben askren ben it's
great to see you how you doing uh i'm
doing great i just got off the i guess
the panel or the desk um it was a lot of
fun last speaker was safety he's such a
legend i love listening to him uh it was
i'm glad to be here we're talking about
the future of payments so do you think
that the world eventually is going to be
transacting in bitcoin uh i don't
i always struggle with that because why
would i spend my bitcoin on something
when it's gaining value it just doesn't
make sense to me so i think it's
probably a combination people hold their
wealth in bitcoin and then they they
move it into something else to transact
um would be kind of my guess yeah i
totally agree with you i also feel
uncomfortable about the idea of spending
my bitcoin so what are you most excited
for about the event today uh i think
jack mallors i hope he makes a really
cool announcement i hope he doesn't let
us down put all kinds of pressure on
this man
let's rock this thing absolutely thank
you so much ben you got it thanks leo